I almost wore a bunny suit I wish we saw
a guy at the improv and they wear suit
he look like a [ __ ] [ __ ] ah myself
with a suit as poor girlfriend sitting
there having a good time you one look
it's just something he wears all the
time yeah people are crazy
you don't [ __ ] suckers Joey patois here
this is not a cigarette this is one of
these [ __ ] things I got for Louie
Gomez the other night
it's reefer in many ways you understand
me here at the church we attack you in
many ways here we go a little [ __ ] I
only for you to get you're going with
the Marlin control pilot to Bombardier
there it is are you kidding me or what
[Music]
the bond of life is [ __ ] Sunday Jesus
made a comeback on a Sunday [ __ ]
don't worry about nothing
here we don't mind help my man fan of my
bound you back [ __ ] man
[Applause]
easily keep pumping we're gonna hit this
in two ways is it there's a superset
type of Sunday will fasten the joint and
look at the great
[Music]
looking better than heavy understand me
what more can you do no more tomorrow
life is killing you you understand me
[ __ ] dreams turn to nightmares heaven
tense turns to hell where's that [ __ ]
life
he's smoking he's smoking
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
what
you want
there you go [ __ ] the body of
Christ
oh [ __ ] the body of Christ [ __ ]
and a needs to eat something you follow
me I'll bite get in the [ __ ] box I'll
do whatever you got
that's how we're doing it here today I
have to church and I'm saying look at me
smoking a cigarette like Lee Harvey look
at me I look like Lee Harvey after a
shower
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
living like a doctor [ __ ] you
understand me
there you go Lee we're going deep into
the murky waters we played it from both
directions to show you we come at you
for more [ __ ] angles breathe for
non-research regular public oh man balls
satellites
I got a Martians calling next week I'm
saying are you ready for the bong and
adeptly we got week you dare Anthony's
house [ __ ] on a Sunday is the
Church of what's happening now bringing
the team this is Lee's favorite song
it's called am I going insane
[Music]
and sign happy birthday if it's your
birthday
I don't give a [ __ ] but happy birthday I
don't know whose birthday it is but he
it's always suddenly [ __ ] birthday
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
oh no it's not gonna weed
[Music]
tonio weasels bookstall there we do
I've grinded my toenails and sprinkled
in a weed let's do this let's do this
thing
I don't want no [ __ ] stories if the
lungfish
there you go there you go that's the one
that's the one that's the one that way
let's go to head I know I [ __ ] who gives
a [ __ ]
take a chance Columbus did eyebrows
overrated
[Music]
stabbed in the jugular anyway
good anyway you gotta fill up again the
charge that the we that what I surprised
what I guess [ __ ] that's in the back
room [ __ ] the [ __ ] of 14% law or
whatever I don't deal with those [ __ ]
recreational joints [ __ ] you I got
better [ __ ] to do it my time
[Music]
Oh mommy hit it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] a little Laguna [ __ ] sunrise
cousins to the tequila sunrise a lot of
people didn't know that I thought I'd
drop it on your little bartending now is
there for my days at the American
bartending Institute a lot of people
don't know that
oh [ __ ] here we go a little snowblind
for you [ __ ] is here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] he thought it was Easter
Sunday no days love Carlotta
this is the real crucifix of my face
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] it you're gonna get down you gotta
get down you follow me no [ __ ]
stories let's do this [ __ ] with a man of
many races we got this one the job we
got this one we this is next oh [ __ ]
don't worry about the cameraman [ __ ]
up the cameraman [ __ ] up it's gonna be
a good week don't worry about nothing
whatever happened last week happened
last week this is your lucky week and it
hit the lotto for filing a million but
this week you live for 42 million the
same difference
[Applause]
[Music]
there we go this is a salute right here
my eyes applied but I can see it I'm
saying this is my John Osborne was right
[ __ ] lyrics here
[Music]
I know if it's good
[Music]
oh that's my girl is my girl
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what else you got doing your day Uncle
Joe is here he listened ain't no
president i ain't no congressman ain't
no psychotherapist I got left back in
the seventh grade but we got none but
hardball seein nothin the heart balls
you see on this station Jesus Christ
take Quigley's get more more crazy with
that body
[ __ ] savagery understand me here we go
[Music]
are you ready
[Music]
[Music]
keep away from us I gotta play like
everybody else here we go hit I only hit
oh [ __ ]
here we go why don't you think I know
what I'm doing
[Music]
how many [ __ ] kilos of coke I sold it
to this [ __ ] this is my coke Camp anthem
yeah this is all about [ __ ]
straight-up jacket
[Music]
they relocate watchlist
crystal world would did the flowers
turn my days the frozen hours how you
fun giving me it's not inclined slow
wine in the Sun this is beep yeah with
my ice age yet to come
are you [ __ ] kidding me I was
listening to this is 17 going I'm going
into my own [ __ ] Ice Age and I did
that's why I love 92 but [ __ ] it we're
still here swinging dick and give it our
[ __ ] heart
don't forget what are we doing will we
do it April 14th working out with uncle
Joey at the ice house don't forget 420
and [ __ ] funny ball Columbus with the
beautiful talented cake Quigley and Kate
Quigley I'll be at the [ __ ] stress
factory in Jersey savages you understand
me who the [ __ ] you think you're dealing
with here
Lee yeah let's do it one shot Lou you
know boy who's here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
why show me show that before they even
before when you look at it because he
told me I'm a 20 pound Boise you know
she wears any [ __ ] sides a piece of
meat between them
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
actually all that I'm gonna win I'm a
bunch of losers
[Music]
the only rule is hot
[Music]
unbelievable we're talking around what
we got here twenty thousand kilograms
2.2 pounds is 1 kilo so yeah if it's now
and you will regret seeing the life you
learned before we met
whoa whoo one more bond and then we'll
get this balloon what break there's no
breaks in life there's no breaks in life
is between the one I do what you see
this God to be real oh [ __ ]
before you know this high qualities but
Jeff Sessions lately he's logged qubits
like a little Jeff Sessions
I am a little dress you know and tell
your marijuana go suck my dick Jeff
Sessions there's uncle Joey [ __ ] we do
it this way you wanna do it that way you
do it that way here we go what fan and
fan and a mess
[Music]
you ready for number three here we go
it's [ __ ] let Jesus die it's over you
can eat shakes on Fridays [ __ ] see
you I am that that Lucifer please take
my hand I want to give a shout out to
the [ __ ] Holloway's in Jersey running
things Timmy Timmy Julian and my brother
[ __ ] Roger and my thoughts out with
mr. Holloway always what to go what the
[ __ ] that's an inside joke it'll need to
know that about done here
look at this bucket monster of metal
[Music]
I'll show you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I know these are you gonna do sit on the
couch on the couch and give the council
give the camera to leave I told you you
and I would click we what I as a couple
we can't get together it's no
[Music]
you said you want to say my fault yes
you did I got your hammer yes you did
you didn't leave me somebody says I'm
going to show you my balls I'd be on
roller skates
[Laughter]
that's right if you don't leave I gave
you fair warning
you didn't [ __ ] leave let me tell you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
Oh chase chase by the way cater is a
wholesome where's Dave fails that's why
I'm telling you me and Kate which one
years apart the kids a house family
balls every night one day
tremendous filled it's like a [ __ ]
gallon I'm seeing when we stop I've seen
women women stop put like a little
understated for later and then go back
and Sukup I mean I'll forget about it
you have no idea
yes you do I've had it before cuz
sometimes I gotta I'm a circumcised so
I'll put like a bread tie on it and save
the juice in there for you for later it
swirls look like a snake and then i
blast it later people don't know dick
about nothing nobody's got a childhood
you don't say nobody's got imagination
that's what the problem is in this
country anyway
you do
we should have a picture for Christmas
you sniffing my right ball and leave
sniffing my left ball you're the one
that wants to get [ __ ] video hits I'm
trying to help you out here I had my
balls on Facebook and Twitter for a year
when we had the album until somebody
ratted me out on Twitter you go to the
cover of yeah go to the cover of we
don't [ __ ] around here you gotta miss
Ridgeway I'm nothing but [ __ ] sad you
sure cause I [ __ ] lost weight light
them up
come on let's go stops blowing you stop
this over here stall of [ __ ] there's no
each other know each other I have a big
dear friend that the first time we met
like the second or third time we met we
did none other that's a little half a
[ __ ] bum there I know a little [ __ ]
die I know eight-year-old little Thai
boys that do [ __ ] bigger Bob yeah
oh my [ __ ] listen what you need to do
now is go to youtube.com slash slash
Joey Diaz is [ __ ] not this [ __ ]
madness gonna continue this what happens
okay quick comes to the [ __ ] thing